像以前其實我們沒有什麼
太多的治療方式可以運用
就算脂肪肝
醫師大概就只會跟你說
回去少吃多動
然後就說
好 大家就點點頭就回家了
然後幾年後
發現那脂肪肝其實狀況還是在
不過現在其實
狀況就已經不一樣了
美國FDA就通過這個
也就是我們週纖達
它其實可以用在我們的脂肪肝炎上
對
可以去做一個治療
那也就是說
對於治療的概念
從以前這種等一等啊
觀察放著不理啊
這種方式可以轉變成為
一個比較
的這種概念
大家知道嗎
其實在台灣我們有
也就是說其實在我們的身邊啊
在診間啊
其實很多人就會問我說
脂肪肝這件事情
到底嚴不嚴重
是不是吃太油了
我明明體重只有重了一些
為什麼會有脂肪肝
甚至很多人會跟我說
是不是沒有什麼症狀
我乾脆就不要去理它了
我想其實這件事啊
絕對沒有那麼單純啦
脂肪肝如果說你放著不理
後面有可能演變成為肝硬化
演變成為肝癌
所以它可以說是一個
那我們今天邀請到我們的專家
胃腸肝膽科的專科醫師
雅丰纖境腸胃科診所的院長
鄭以勤院長
魏醫師你好
觀眾朋友大家好
我是雅丰纖境腸胃科診所的
院長鄭以勤
本身是肝膽腸胃科的醫師
那同時因為自己曾經很胖
我也做減重啦
所以對減重也略有涉略
今天很開心可以跟大家聊一下
我們的脂肪肝
跟相關的一些進展
剛剛其實就有跟大家提到
脂肪肝啊
不是大家想像
那麼單純的一件事情
現實的生活當中呢
有很多大家熟悉的公眾人物啊
甚至是他們家人
也都曾經公開談過自己
面對脂肪肝
處理肝臟疾病的經驗
那接下來
我想跟大家分享這些案例
不是因為他們是名人
主要是因為他們的經歷啊
其實剛好可以幫助我們
去打破一些
對於脂肪肝還有肝病的
一些迷思
我想接下來就請鄭醫師
帶著我們從專業角度
去看這些案例
可以讓我們去知道
哪些是真正我們值得注意的風險
第一位我們就從歌手A-Lin開始好了
其實我對她印象是一個
很健康啊
陽光的這種形象
知道她有脂肪肝的時候
其實我有點訝異啦
沒錯
那不光是魏醫師
我想光我自己看到新聞的時候
我也是嚇到啦
我想說A-Lin欸
她有脂肪肝喔
那當然更深入的去
挖掘新聞的一些細節
大概還是會知道一些小魔鬼啦
那A-Lin大概有表示過
就是她的三餐啊
飲食上可能沒辦法那麼正常
畢竟是藝人
那第二個是
她有一些飲酒的習慣
我們在臨床上啊
雖然都叫作脂肪肝
但實際上是有分成酒精性脂肪肝
或者是其他原因造成的脂肪肝
那實務上
就算是肝臟腸胃科醫師
也不容易從超音波
或者是他臨床表現上去做判斷
必須要病人本身告訴我們
他喝了多少酒
由病史端去做詢問
我們才可以知道這些蛛絲馬跡
那才能告訴他說
他的脂肪肝的原因是什麼
那以A-Lin的案例來講
她後來好像就也比較少喝
甚至就停止飲酒了
那我想
那我知道聽到這邊
一定非常多的觀眾朋友都會問
不是說喝紅酒
喝微量的酒
適量的酒
對心血管疾病有幫助
那我要再次強調
我是肝膽腸胃科醫師
所以任何量的酒精
對我們來說都是有害的
我想以我家醫科角度一樣
都是有害的
心臟科自己講的
自己擔我們沒有要承認
第二位我們來討論的
就是我們的藝人黃靖倫
那其實跟現代人
很多會遇到的狀況一樣就是
生活面臨一陣子的低潮
然後壓力很大
甚至聽說他有一陣子
月收只有三千元
那不過我比較訝異
就是他那個飲食習慣
好像很喜歡吃火鍋
尤其是麻辣鍋
不去油的也要喝那個湯
喝個四碗這樣子
對 所以仔細看
其實年紀好像也沒有說很大
然後其實體重也還好
對 然後腰圍你說35吋
其實還可以
可是居然也有一個
中重度的脂肪肝
那第一個
要先幫大家破解迷思
很多人都覺得脂肪肝
是胖子的專利
其實在統計上
大約也可能一成多的人
是有脂肪肝的
肝臟是個受害者
當我們的生活
我們的飲食不正常的時候
它可能就會囤積一些脂肪
那為你承受一些傷害
以黃靖倫的例子
因為他的飲食實在太不正常了
包括麻辣鍋或者炸物
一些加工食品
或者是高油
高鹹的這些食物
久了對身體總是會造成負擔
那另外一個
還有一個小小有趣的事
你在醫學上
會說脂肪肝跟肥胖
有時候會跟你的社經地位
跟你的收入有關
這個其實也好想像
就是要吃到比較高纖
或者是好好煮過的食物
總是會比較昂貴一點
所以我相信在他
比較困難的時候
月收3000塊
可能飲食上的選擇
只能選一些像便利商店
或者是加工的微波的食品
久了對肝臟就會有
不等程度的危害
對 其實像我自己的經驗
帶著個案去調飲食的時候
第一次問他說
這樣調整
有沒有什麼地方不適應
他們最常跟我說就
對 我自己曾經也很胖
那我試著吃減重餐的時候
也是從便利商店開始
一盒蔬菜
然後一個水果
再加上一個飯糰
兩顆茶葉蛋
一個雞胸肉
大概都要200多塊
對
不過當你慢慢的
知道那個訣竅的時候
其實你會覺得這個錢
還是花得值得
或者自己煮省很多
那接下來我們
討論比較嚴重的案例
就是我們大家熟知的
大甲鎮瀾宮的董事長顏清標
C型肝炎的帶原者
然後後面就進展成肝硬化
然後肝癌
甚至面臨需要換肝的一個狀況
B、C肝這兩種病毒性的肝炎
一直是台灣過去的國民病
那首先還是要非常感謝腸胃科
肝膽科的前輩們努力
藥物公衛防治越來越好之後
其實B、C肝已經慢慢在絕跡了
但是還是要提醒大家
如果有C肝的話
第一個它目前已經可以治療了
所以如果真的有觀眾朋友
不知道這個訊息
但你知道自己有C肝
務必到醫院診所去做治療
第二個是C肝非常容易
合併脂肪化的現象
它跟病毒本身破壞肝臟
造成一些空洞化有關
脂肪就會趁機趁隙而入
那造成脂肪化的現象
所以我想以標哥的例子
他因為有C肝
可能還有些
應酬的需要
或許會飲酒
導致了脂肪肝跟C肝
共同的破壞
才會讓他
但是看看新聞他後來
好像也調整蠻多了
換完肝之後目前應該還蠻好的
他很好我們才不會變消波塊
真是萬幸啊對不對
基本上我們從前面這些案例
看下來會發現
其實脂肪肝這件事不挑人的
想問鄭醫師
如果說
脂肪肝並不是跟我們的外表
胖瘦有關的話
那到底這個脂肪
是為什麼會堆積在肝臟
到底後面的機轉是怎麼回事
脂肪肝到底為什麼會形成
那它其實有點像
我們手頭有錢了之後
總是會存到銀行去
那如果你攝取的熱量過度了
它可能就會囤積在
我們的內臟裡面
當作儲備用
某天你遇到飢荒的時候
就會需要拿它出來
那有些人有小誤會
想說我不要吃油
是不是就不會脂肪肝
我們只要賺的錢夠多
就會想辦法買股票
買其他東西
那身體一樣有個檸檬酸循環
會把你攝取的熱量
轉化為脂肪做儲存
我就有一個案例非常非常特別
那個是我診所的一個夥伴
說實話還真的非常瘦
大概就是四十幾不到五十公斤
150多公分
30多歲
因為當時我們在籌備要開
腸胃科診所
所以在嘗試一些超音波的
各家廠牌好不好在做挑選
那時候我就幫她一掃超音波
我發現
中度幾乎是重度的脂肪肝
那她也是嚇一跳
因為她想說我那麼瘦
為什麼會有
但是回過頭看她的生活習慣
她老公是工程師
下班都很晚
她常常就是
八、九點以後才能吃東西
當時又沒有什麼開著的店
那可能就是街邊路口的一些
鹽酥雞啊
雞排這一類的東西
就還蠻常吃的
導致她有這個脂肪肝的現象
當然我們就是發現之後
鼓勵她改變飲食
但超音波還是繼續試
那後來就有一家
比較新的超音波
我們一掃
發現除了脂肪肝之外
竟然還有一個兩公分多的腫瘤
也要提醒觀眾朋友
就是我們的脂肪肝
不但只是一種脂肪化現象
它也可能造成肝硬化
或者是後續
有肝腫瘤、癌症的發生
其實很多人會覺得說
泡芙人這樣的案例
大部分發生在女生身上
不過我必須說其實男生
男生其實也會遇到這樣的事情
像我最近也是有一個個案
42歲的竹科工程師
他是167公分
體重是63.8公斤
所以BMI其實也在22.9
如果說你只看數據的話
你會覺得這就是一個
標準的體態
標準體型
當然沒有什麼減重的需求
不過他其實生活也是一團亂
工作壓力其實是很大
所以大概都會加班
熬夜到一點才去睡
然後每天大概睡的時間
不會到六個小時
他跟我說睡到六個小時
算很不錯了這樣子
飲食習慣其實也是一團亂
早餐就是大家熟知的什麼
奶茶配蛋餅
然後午晚餐就是那種
一般外面的便當
飯一定是滿滿的
不然就是麵食
更不用說手搖飲
平常也很愛吃水果
水果量幾乎沒有在限制的
壓力大
宵夜也一定要有
這種狀況之下
其實他遇到的三個問題
就是一個
精緻碳水化合物的過量攝取
其實胰島素阻抗會產生
然後第二個就是在這種壓力
作息不穩定的狀態之下
其實他的皮質醇
非常的不平衡
腹部脂肪也堆積得非常快
更不用說他沒有時間去運動
所以這個狀況其實也會造成
他的肌肉流失
三個問題交錯在一起之後
他就發現
其實他雖然體態還是OK的
可是實際上在我們的檢測之下
就發現體脂率居然超過30%
除此之外
他也有一個中重度的脂肪肝
一個很典型的那種
外表看起來還OK
可是裡面其實代謝
已經一團糟的狀況
現在點擊右上方連結
一分鐘測驗
測出你的脂肪肝風險
如同剛剛鄭醫師和我們有談到的
就是說很多人
以為這個脂肪肝
只是肝臟油一點
或者說體重重一點的表現
沒有症狀我們就放著不管
不需要去理會它
但我們已經知道了
它沒有那麼單純
那甚至我們其實醫學界在這幾年
對於脂肪肝這件事情
我們其實一直在觀念有在進步
有在轉變
甚至它連名字都不一樣了
從我們的
轉變成
這個正名運動
到底對於我們醫學上是說
我們過去忽略了什麼
那對一般民眾又有什麼意義呢
我們的脂肪肝
在過去會分成
兩個主要的原因
一個是因為喝酒引起的
酒精性脂肪肝
一個是其他原因引起的叫作
非酒精性脂肪肝
那為什麼過去
我們一直不大重視它
我想大概幾個原因
一個是它盛行率非常高
好多人都有
同溫層有夠厚
所以說你有我有
那好像不管它
那加上第二個也確實
就是在醫療上
沒有非常好應對的方法
那到底為什麼
脂肪肝這件事重要
第一件事情
所謂的脂肪肝
指的是你的
那這些脂肪
會造成你的肝臟
慢慢的空洞化
然後慢慢的腫大
大家如果有印象的話
有吃過像鵝肝
鴨肝這樣的東西
就會知道
牠的肝實在是有夠好吃
美味
有夠肥
這些脂肪
會因為某些慢性發炎的原因
漸漸的變成了肝炎
肝炎大家都知道
我們可能GOT、GPT會上升
肝細胞會被破壞
有點像是你的皮膚
就是受到一些慢性
不管是過敏
或者是其他傷害都好
它可能一開始
就會有一些紅腫
腫大的現象
久了之後身體會想修復它
就會讓它有點像
結疤 、癒合的過程
那個過程在肝裡面發生
就叫纖維化
所以我們儲存了脂肪
脂肪發炎
造成身體想修復而纖維化
這個過程是很緩慢的
而且是沒有知覺的
很多人就會以為它無害
但實際上這樣的過程
經過二、三十年之後
是可能因為嚴重的纖維化
而變成肝硬化的
那所謂的肝硬化就叫做
No return
就是沒有回頭路的那個界點
就叫肝硬化
所以一旦面臨肝硬化的問題
你可能接下來就要考慮
做一些進一步的處置
譬如說你真的黃膽不退
腹水不退
那另一點是這樣子的肝硬化
或者這樣的病程
大家都知道
肝癌一直是十大癌症前五名
很多人一直都覺得
它只是B肝、C肝的專利
但實際上每年
一萬多個肝癌的患者裡
有兩成是因為脂肪肝形成的
那它比例其實也不少
可以預期在未來
B、C肝控制好之後
因為它是二、三十年後的事
所以也恐嚇一下大家
如果你有的話
它是一種
那現在又有一些好的治療方式
好的追蹤方式
那我想你就應該要
其實我們會發現
現在這個診斷命名的改變
對我們來說是
沒錯
那現在其實我們把這個診斷
從這個排除性的診斷
把它變成一個肯定式的診斷
它就變成說我只要確認有脂肪肝
同時我合併五個代謝風險因子
像是體重過重
血壓的問題
血糖的問題
然後還有血脂肪
包含三酸甘油脂
跟高密度脂蛋白的問題
當它有任何其中一項亮紅字
我們就可以說
我們其實是有一個
代謝障礙相關性的脂肪肝病
這是什麼意思呢
就是告訴我們說
脂肪肝阿
它可能不是一個原因
它其實是一個結果
所以我們真正要治療脂肪肝
其實治療背後的那個
過去我們在看到脂肪肝的時候
一直好像有點小誤解
就覺得它是個原因
所以應該就是單純的看它就好
那越來越多證據顯示
那代謝又不單純
只跟體重有關
它也跟其他的一些慢性狀況有關
當我們認知越來越清楚之後
會回到源頭
我們要控制的
應該就是這個過程
包括生活習慣、飲食
或者是一些慢性的代謝性疾病
造成的發炎
可能就會追本溯源
後面很多事情就會跟著改善
對
這就是為什麼在醫療上
對於脂肪肝這件事情
感覺越來越能夠去掌握它了
像以前其實我們沒有什麼
太多的治療方式可以運用
就算脂肪肝
醫師大概就只會跟你說
回去少吃多動
然後就說
好 大家就點點頭就回家了
然後幾年後
發現那脂肪肝其實狀況還是在
不過現在其實
狀況就已經不一樣了
美國FDA就通過這個
也就是我們週纖達
它其實可以用在我們的脂肪肝炎上
對
可以去做一個治療
那也就是說
對於治療的概念
從以前這種等一等啊
觀察放著不理啊
這種方式可以轉變成為
一個比較
的這種概念
那我想鄭醫師
可不可以幫助大家
來釐清一下說
這個藥物啊
它是如何在脂肪肝上面
幫助我們取得進展的
是
先幫大家報告一下
這個藥物到底為什麼可以治療
或者是改善我們的脂肪肝
肝纖維化
第一件事情啊
剛剛我們提到了
脂肪肝變成硬化、肝癌
是要二、三十年的時間
它非常的久
藥廠它在做臨床試驗的時候
它其實設計的時間也非常的久
它一開始實驗設計
是要五年的追蹤時間
所以先跟大家報告好消息
在去年的時候
它做期中的一個報告
就是它實驗還沒做完
但是它發現在第七十幾週的時候
已經可以證實藥物
會對脂肪肝、纖維化
有非常明確的效果
所以它在這個階段先發了報告
那也因為這一份報告
所以美國的 FDA 就核准
它可以用來治療脂肪肝
造成的纖維化
報告裡面有幾個點還蠻有趣的
那大概三分之二左右的人
它的發炎是會得到緩解的
大概三分之一左右的人
它的纖維化會得到改善
所以是這兩個重大的結果
導致 FDA 允許它
拿來治療脂肪肝纖維化
我們會想說
那到底是為什麼
為什麼這個藥有效
週纖達 （Semaglutide)這個藥物
它具有某種程度抗發炎的效果
它在心血管的預防上已經有證實了
那目前在脂肪肝上
得到進一步的證實
剛剛提到有三分之二的人
會因為使用這個藥
而達到
它的發炎緩解的這個效果
脂肪肝發炎好了
剛剛聽到鄭醫師
提到這麼多的機轉
我其中有一個覺得印象非常深刻
就是對於纖維化
其實也可以改變
因為
傳統上好像有一種觀念就是說
肝臟在因為發炎之後纖維化
它好像就像我們皮膚受傷之後
那個疤痕一樣
基本上就很難去逆轉了
沒想到它居然對
纖維化這件事情
也可以有一定程度的改善
我想請問鄭醫師說
所以目前數據上
對於纖維化這件事情
它到底可以提供多少的幫忙
能夠讓我們的肝臟
回春到什麼樣子
在纖維化上
我們會分成四種程度
就是 F0 到 F4
這個不等程度
其實它要逆轉的困難度
就會逐層上升
就像你身上的疤越大
或者是它越深
本來就不容易完全恢復
反過來說
如果我們受點小傷
你只要好好照顧它
它是會恢復的
肝的情況一模一樣
在臨床試驗裡面
肝硬化的患者
我們是沒有去include的
因為它實在太難逆轉了
所以它暫時不是我們的 target
如果在 F2、F3 的這個族群
就是它已經開始纖維化
而且離硬化好像也開始越來越不遠了
這個族群在用藥72週之後
大概有三分之一的人
它的纖維化程度
是可以往前一個等級的
因為它只是個期中報告
我們本來預期是要追蹤五年
目前只追蹤了一年多
就已經得到了相當程度的緩解
那我想未來更多的數據
應該都會再表明
它其實效果或許會再好一些
所以我想我們經過這麼多的分享
請鄭醫師再幫我們總結一下
我們面對這個脂肪肝這件事情
我們應該以什麼樣的態度
或是說以什麼樣的方式來去面對
第一個就是打破你的同溫層
不要再鴕鳥
脂肪肝實在太多人有
但大家好像不以為意
不以為意的情況下
就會出現
零星的有點悲劇
剛剛有提到
脂肪肝發炎
造成纖維化
硬化、腫瘤
這個大概只佔所有脂肪肝
model裡面的可能一成多左右
但是這一群人有脂肪肝
儘管沒有發炎
但它得到肝癌的風險
可能也是
1‰到1%左右
其實也不少
如果台灣有那麼多人
有脂肪肝的話
乘上1%
其實那個量也蠻多的
所以當我們開始越來越注重
自己的健康跟未來的時候
那你已經明確知道有個疾病危險
在它還沒有真的變嚴重前
去介入
就會是比較適合的時候
那很多人聽到藥物
都會覺得有點恐懼
只要我們好好的使用它
看待它
它就是個非常棒的工具
可以幫我們解決很多的疾病跟問題
這麼說好了
我其實覺得藥物的角色
在我們這些脂肪肝的治療
越來越吃重了
如果說把身體著火
拿來描述脂肪肝的那件事情
其實藥物就是一個
但是如果說我想要讓這個身體
以後不要再次的起火
不要再次著火的話
生活習慣的調整
就會是根基了
包含你的飲食
包含你的運動
睡眠
和壓力調節
所以其實藥物的使用
或者是生活的調整
它其實
先用藥物
讓我們的身體受傷的狀況
趕快恢復到正常
然後接下來再透過生活調整
讓我們的身體
可以回到健康的軌道上
那我想我們今天很感謝鄭醫師
跟我們這樣如此詳細的分享
如果說大家感覺到有收穫的話
別忘了按讚、分享、訂閱
那我們下支影片再見囉
掰掰
謝謝大家